le coeur de ces grandes mécanique
cela fait cinq ans qu'il bat
inlassablement au rythme de plusieurs
milliers de fils de soie des métiers à
tisser de type jacquard doté d'un
système de cartes perforées véritable
ancêtre de l'ordinateur des machines
séculaire que lui rien a appris à
diriger
il y a dix sept ans au tout début quand
j'ai commencé à travaillé et appris à
travailler sur ces métiers là c'était
très impressionnant et ça me rend des
tiers je sais que quand on me demande le
métier que je fais que je dis que je
suis tisseuse je le dis avec avec fierté
un travail dont la patience et la
rigueur le disputent aux plaisirs de la
confection d'un textile hors du commun
au programme aujourd'hui une toile de
type montrichard quitté le fil jaune
d'or un rouleau de 20 m sortira bientôt
de la machine on affinity c est que nous
on coupe on prend le tissu au magasin et
qu'on déroule pour voir le métrage que
nous avons faits puis le résultat de nos
efforts c'est très c'est très
satisfaisant parce qu'il ya des fois on
fait des métiers enfin fait des tissus
100 % soit et le rendu de mon petit coin
des étoffes qui rejoindront ensuite les
étals des tapissiers décorateurs
traditionnellement la soie et le
matériau le plus utilisé mais ici on
tisse aussi d'autres fils pour créer des
effets de matière comme avec ce tissu
persan dont le modèle date du xviiie
siècle
il est réalisé en soi et en lin une
chaîne en soi qui est très chine et une
trame en lin qui est plus épaisse qui
permet de réaliser un motif en volume et
donc vous avez naturellement ce motif
qui apparaît avec une sur épaisseur ont
touché chanvre lin soie ou encore phil
suit des tiges de tomates la maison rose
fabrique à la demande des motifs les
plus anciens datant de la création de
l'entreprise il ya trois cent soixante
ans aux créations contemporaines tout ou
presque est possible grâce à mon métier
technique jacquard et nos cartons
justement on peut vraiment reproduire
tous les dessins depuis 20 ans 30 ans en
temps et donc on peut reprendre les
archives et réinterpréter les dessins
aujourd'hui et en plus ça une collection
justement peut être travailler avec un
thème nouveau faire du sur mesure avec
mes pneus à la tête de la maison rose
depuis deux ans arnaud le vert s'est
pris de passion pour un savoir faire
qu'il veut résolument tourné vers
l'avenir développer une marque mais
aussi étendre le champ des possibles
au delà du simple textile l'idée c'est
d'amener rose à être un acteur majeur de
la décoration d'intérieur
il ya un parcours dans l'histoire de
rose qui est lié à au tapis notamment on
est en train de râler sur les papiers
peints sur des tissus pas la planche
avec l'atelier dhofar voilà c'est les
entreprises emblématiques de savoir
faire exceptionnel mais ce fils
d'ébéniste nourrit un autre projet celui
de replanter des mûriers en touraine
comme au temps de louis ozoux tour était
alors berceau de l'élevage de vers à
soie de poids renouer avec le fil de
l'histoire